The Black Death. Explain like you are 5.
Step 1. 1347. Ships dock in Sicily. The sailors are dead or dying. Black
swellings the size of eggs on their necks and groins bleeding from every opening.
The port authorities order the ships back to sea. Too late. Within days, people in
the port town are showing the same symptoms. Within weeks, it is moving north.
Nobody knows what it is. Nobody knows how it spreads. Nobody knows how to stop it.
Step 2. It moves faster than news of it. It kills in days, sometimes hours, a fever,
then the swellings, then black patches on the skin as blood vessels burst beneath,
then death. Entire households wiped out overnight.
Priests refuse to give last rites. Doctors refuse to enter sick homes.
Bodies pile in the streets faster than they can be buried. Mass graves outside every city.
Step 3. People blame the Jews. They blame the planets. They blame God's punishment
for human sin. They try prayers, bloodletting, burning aromatic herbs.
Flagellants walk between cities whipping themselves bloody to appease God. Nothing
works because nobody understands that it is bacterial, carried by fleas,
living on rats, traveling on every trade route in Europe.
Step 4. In four years, 25 million dead. One third of Europe erased. Entire villages emptied.
Economies collapse. Feudalism crumbles. But from the devastation, change.
Labor becomes scarce. Scarce labor becomes valuable. Peasants demand rights. Wages rise.
The rigid medieval social order shatters. The renaissance emerges from the plague pit.
The Black Death didn't just kill a third of Europe. It ended the Middle Ages.
And that's just one story inside Paladin. It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Download it now and become the most intelligent person in the room.